today is tax day it's the day that all
Americans but one release their tax
records it's a big deal to get together
this has been a Trump is busy guy these
days yeah
his latest president Trump has begun
hiring more people from president george
w bush's administration that's what he's
doing yeah he's hiring people from
president george bush administration in
fact from specifically asked for the
iraq guy and the katrina guy those guys
they're the best this is a little
strange a little hard to understand this
one several days ago President Trump
said an aircraft carrier it was headed
toward North Korea but it turns out that
this is an American aircraft carrier
yeah was headed towards North Korea it
turns out it's actually been sailing in
the opposite direction that's right it's
the aircraft carrier the USS metaphor
interesting phase thank you thank you
it's good now thank you no that's right
it is my birthday after all
with the same
I'm just saying if the jokes just kind
of okay you're given an electron so I'm
saying
who else is going on a Republican
lawmaker who was criticized about his
vote against internet privacy said
nobody's got to use the Internet
that's what he said he said no one's got
to use the Internet then send someone
told him that's where porn was and he
said I've been a fool
[Applause]
it's my patented move when the wife
walks in and then this way and then that
it's a to move in front of the screen
and turn around I said I just why don't
you turn the desk around oh you mean
this way yeah yeah yeah and then it's
like hello honey
I meant for wouldn't know why I hiss in
I guess like a vampire when I'm caught
watching poor and I hiss like a vampire
hi it's my patented move what's going on
in New York a Southwest Airlines pilot
was arrested for having a loaded gun
hidden in his carry-on bag pilot was
fired from Southwest immediately hired
by United
you know we're hearing about
self-driving cars how that's the wave of
the future researchers are now using the
video game Grand Theft Auto to teach to
teach this is true they're using Grand
Theft Auto to cheat self-driving cars
how to drive that's true yeah in fact to
Google cars were just arrested for
beating up a hooker a radio station in
Austin is holding a contest called kiss
a Kia that has 20 people standing around
kissing a Kia last person standing wins
the car yeah let's hope this goes better
than last year's contest humph a Hyundai
finger a Fiat remember that
[Applause]
that's the kind of show you've come to
tonight let's go
you